DOUG JONES CAMPAIGN.
SEAN, BACK TO YOU.
SEAN SEAN BY THE WAY, AS WE
BRING IN OUR PANEL HERE,
CONSERVATIVE UNION CHAIRMAN
MATT SCHLAPP.
SALEM NATIONALLY SYNDICATED
MATT ELDER.
JOE CONCHA, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
FORMER DOUG SCHOEN AND TAMMY
BRUCE.
RIGHT NOW IT'S 54%.
"NEW YORK TIMES" HAS IT
BOUNCING AROUND LIKE A
PING-PONG BALL AND WE ARE
ALL SITTING HERE
NEUROTICALLY LOOKING.
MENTIONED TALLADEGA COUNTY.
I WOULD SAY ANOTHER COUNTY
CERTAIN COUNTIES TO THE
NORTH.
ROY MOORE IS GOING TO WANT
TO RUN OCCUPY THE VOTE AS
MUCH AS HE POSSIBLY CAN
THERE IN THE BIRMINGHAM AREA
CERTAIN DEMOCRATIC AREAS THE
SAME WITH DOUG JONES.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE, TAMMY?
>> LOOK, I THINK ONE OF THE
BIG BENEFITS ROY MOORE HAS
IS THE HISTORY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THERE IS NEVER REALLY BEEN I
THINK A COMPETITIVE RACE
THERE BETWEEN THE DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS FOR A COUPLE
DECADES.
YOU ALSO HAVE -- THEY KNOW
ROY MOORE.
SOME THINGS MAY SURPRISE
BASIC AMERICANS.
AMERICANS NOT IN ALABAMA.
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S ABOUT GETTING OUT THE
VOTE.
RIGHT NOW ROY MOORE AND THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAVE THE
EDGE.
>> Sean: LET ME BRING IN
BRIT HUME ELDER STATESMAN HE
HAS SEEN A CAMPAIGN OR TWO
ALSO A CLOSE FRIEND OF OURS.
BRIT, THANKS FOR BEING WITH
US.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
NATIONAL IMPLICATIONS FOR A
MINUTE.
I KNOW THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT WERE DEAD SET
AGAINST SUPPORTING ROY
MOORE.
AT THE END THEY ENDED UP
COMING.
HE WENT CLOSE TO THE STATE.
HE ALSO POINTED OUT THAT FOR
HIM, WITH THE SENATE
MARGINAL OF 52-48, GOING
DOWN TO 51-49 BECOMES
INTOLERABLE AND MEANS YOU
NEED THE ENTIRE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS TO PASS A
BILL.
>> THAT'S TRUE, SEAN.
INDEED THE REPUBLICAN
LEADERSHIP IN WASHINGTON
REMAINED DIVIDED OVER ROY
MOORE'S CANDIDACY.
THE PRESIDENT AND WITH IT --
WITH HIM THE REPUBLICAN
NATIONAL COMMITTEE SWUNG
BEHIND HIM BUT THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN LEADERSHIP DID
NOT.
NOR DID THE NATIONAL
REPUBLICAN SENATORIAL
COMMITTEE WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT SOURCE OF SUPPORT
FOR ANY CANDIDATE RUNNING
REMAINS, SEAN, AND VERY
MOORE, IF ELECTED, WHILE HE
WOULD BE AN ALLY ON MANY
ISSUES VOTING, WOULD BE A
PROBLEM FOR REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR
SENATE NEXT YEAR.
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS WILL BE
CLAIMING THAT THEY DISPOSED
OF AND DISCIPLINED ALL OF
THEIR ALLEGED SEXUAL
OFFENDERS AND HERE IS ROY
MOORE WHO, AGAINST WHOM
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
SO, THAT'S THE DILEMMA.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT.
AND OBVIOUSLY, THEY CAN'T
WIN EITHER WAY, SEAN,
BECAUSE EITHER THEY LOSE THE
SEAT OR THEY GAIN WHAT THEY
THINK MAY BE AN ANVIL AROUND
THE EXIT POLLS AND NUMBERS
WE ARE SEEING EARLY ON HERE,
IF HE WERE TO PULL THIS OUT,
WE KNOW THE SENATE MAJORITY
LEADER MITCH MCCONNELL 10:00
A.M. SCHEDULED CONFERENCE
IF THEY DECIDE TO DO AN
ETHICS INVESTIGATION, IF
THEY WOULD THEN AGGRESSIVELY
RESULTS OF THIS ELECTION,
WHAT WOULD BE THE IMPACT OR
RESULTS, HOW WOULD THE
PEOPLE OF ALABAMA FEEL?
>> HE WILL WITH, I THINK THE
PEOPLE OF ALABAMA AT LEAST
THOSE WHO VOTED FOR ROY
MOORE WOULD BE FURIOUS.
I DON'T THINK THERE IS ANY
THAT THESE REPUBLICANS IN
THE SENATE WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE.
IS IT WORTH IT?
IS HE ENOUGH OF A BURDEN TO
THEM AS THEY SEEK TO
MAINTAIN THEIR MAJORITY NEXT
YEAR THAT IT WOULD BE WORTH
THE CANDLE?
AND, OF COURSE, YOU KNOW,
THIS IS ONLY A SPECIAL
ELECTION, THERE WILL HAVE TO
BE A REGULAR ELECTION GOING
FORWARD.
ALABAMA REMAINS AN
AND I THINK THE BELIEF AMONG
SENATE REPUBLICANS, SEAN IS
THAT HAD THEY NOMINATED
EITHER MO BROOKS OR LUTHER
STRANGE, THAT EITHER OF
THOSE CANDIDATES WOULD BE
WAY AHEAD TONIGHT INSTEAD OF
BEING IN THIS CLOSE RACE
THAT THEY MIGHT LOSE.
I MIGHT ADD, SEAN, YOU MAY
RECALL LAST YEAR ON ELECTION
NIGHT I KEPT QUOTING THE
BETTING ODDS PUT TOGETHER BY
OUR COLLEAGUES JOHN STOSSEL
RIGHT NOW BETTING ODDS HAVE
MOORE 73%, JONES 26%.
THAT'S WHAT THE BETTING ODDS
ARE SHOWING RIGHT NOW.
WE MAY RECALL LAST YEAR WHEN
THE NIGHT LAST YEAR AND THEY
TURNED OUT -- THE BETTING
ODDS TURNED OUT RIGHT TO
THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S IT
HERE.
>> Sean: PEOPLE THOUGHT
TRUMP HAD A MUCH BETTER